our research shows that your thoughts
could make you sick and the question is
if your thoughts could make you sick and
your thoughts make you well that's
absolutely possible and it's easy to
learn so when you wake up in the morning
Dr Joe dispenza researcher and
best-selling author one of the most
sought after speakers in the world all
with the aim of helping people better
understand and unlock the power of their
minds I'm concerned about human species
why 75 to 90 percent of every person
that goes to a health care facility goes
because of psychological or emotional
stress and gets addictive to people they
need the bad relationship the bad job in
order to feel and there's so much
research to show that when they analyze
their life within some disturbing
emotion we saw that they were actually
making the brain worse but fifty percent
of that story isn't even the truth
people are reliving a miserable life
they never even had just to excuse
themselves from changing you can't wait
for your wealth to feel success you
can't wait for your new relationship to
feel love but 95 of Who We Are by the
age of 35 is programmed yeah but there
is a way to change and so the model of
change is breaking the habit of the old
self and Reinventing a new self but if
you teach people how to do that in seven
days you can see very significant
changes so try this out as an experiment
first thing you have to do is
Dr Joe you're someone that's constantly
doing research and developing new ideas
about way humans are and the way the
universe is what are the beliefs in your
head that you're too scared to share oh
boy I I have a very strong belief that
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
foreign
[Music]
95 of Who We Are by the age of 35 is
programmed
when I read that in your work kind of
hit me like a
ton of bricks because I just turned 30.
and if what you're saying there is true
without realizing it there's a puppet
master that sits above me that's calling
the shots in a way that I don't think
I've realized
is that true
I think if we Define a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through repetition it happens
when you've done something so many times
that your body now knows how to do it
better than your conscious mind then
it's programmed subconsciously
so that when the body knows how to do it
better than the conscious mind then for
the most part the greatest habit we have
to break is the habit of being ourselves
right so there's a principle of
Neuroscience that says that nerve cells
that fire together wire together
if you keep thinking the same way yeah
if you keep making the same choices if
you keep doing the same things if you
keep reproducing the same experiences
and feeling the same emotions
your biology begins to become hardwired
in a sense it it becomes programmed
so in order to change something to
arrive at a new vision of your future if
you were wanted to arrive at a new goal
or New Vision of your future you'd have
to change something about yourself in
order to get there
and you'd have to change the way you
think the way you act and the way you
feel
when you begin to become conscious
of those unconscious thoughts so
conscious that you don't let them slip
by your awareness unnoticed or unchecked
by you if you catch yourself speaking in
a limited way or you're you become
conscious that you're behaving in a
certain way in a habit
and you can notice or pay attention to
how you're feeling then you're no longer
the program how your Consciousness
observing the program you're only
unconscious when you're in the program
and so to change then
is to become so conscious that you don't
don't go unconscious again and in a
sense that is consciousness that is
really the puppet master that really
decides who we want to be
I think the biggest problem uh is that
people lose their free will
to a set of programs and so their body
is basically programmed into predictable
future based on what they've done in the
past so to change then to change that
habituation takes an enormous amount of
energy
an enormous amount of awareness
why is this operating system this
program useful because I look at
everything that I the way that I do and
from doing this podcast and speaking to
experts I've stopped thinking that my
body is against me and I've stopped
realize I've started to realize that
there's a reason for these things
there's a reason for the habits and
patterns and so why is this useful
because it seems to be working against
me in so many ways well
um first of all
um
when we when we look closely at certain
habits whether you um can ride a bicycle
whether you can speak a language whether
you can snowboard when you first learn
any of those things it takes an enormous
amount of conscious awareness to get
your body to do what your mind is
intending
but if you keep doing it over and over
again then the body begins to economize
it in some way and so we have a lot of
things that we can do automatically
or unconsciously or subconsciously that
allows us to multitask to drive your car
to talk on the phone to do several
different things at the same time so a
habit isn't a bad thing they can work
for you or they can work against you the
problem is is if you're as an example
complaining
and blaming and making excuses and
feeling sorry for yourself and judging
other people and you practice that and
you get really good at whatever you
practice you practice that enough times
that you're unconscious to the fact that
you're doing it
um
the moment you become conscious that you
want to change that you're going to be
uncomfortable it's going to feel
unfamiliar it's going to feel some
degree of uncertainty you're leaving
kind of familiar known territory and
you're stepping into the unknown and so
many people when they want to change a
habit
um
they have to be willing to be
uncomfortable to do it but habits can
work for us there's a lot of great
habits that you and I both have that I
would never want to change
or would want to evolve in some way but
then there's a lot of habits that don't
serve us and and so a person really
wants to set a vision of the future
whatever that is and they just have to
agree that in order to arrive at that
Vision they have to change in order to
get there someone said to me that
there's a certain type of behavior
pattern that we can't change they said
when we get truma into the age of 10
things that happen at very early age
some of those things cannot be changed
and then there's things that happen
later in life that can be rewired and
changed
is that true are there some traumas
Behavior patterns that just appear to be
too stubborn and too resistant to change
if you ask me that question just a few
years ago I probably would have a
different answer than I do today because
if you look at a lot of the work uh that
we're studying in terms of human change
and human transformation
um
we've seen people with really difficult
pasts really brutal pasts that were
abused and traumatized at a very early
age and then
repeated traumas that took place in
people's lives
and they had night terrors and uh they
couldn't be in relationships they had
social anxiety they had a lot of health
conditions
we've seen them completely change
completely changed to be happy people
again to
to free themselves from the past and so
I would never put a limitation
on change because I just don't think
you can really predict that I think many
people that are learning how to change
and they understand what they're doing
and why they're doing it and how it gets
easier I think for the most part people
can change all kinds of things and when
they do change
our research shows that their brain
changes their heart rate changes their
gene expression changes there's
thousands of metabolites that are being
released into their bloodstream that
weren't there prior
there's a host of different changes that
take place biologically that kind of
support the person's transformation
is that a specific transformation
that sticks in your mind
as being the most as the clearest
evidence that you should never write off
someone's ability to transform
wow
um
I'm so pleased to tell you that my
beliefs have been challenged
just in the last two years in witnessing
so many different changes in people's
Health that I I never knew was even
possible
you know everything from
stage four cancers that were in a very
progressed state that metastasized to
organs and tissues and bones in the body
a complete reversal in uh in that health
condition not once not twice not three
times we've seen it many times
uh we've seen people that were blind
that have been deaf that
that have ALS that have Lupus that have
MS that have Parkinson's disease that
have spinal cord injuries that have
strokes
PTSD
myasthenia gravis cystic fibrosis
muscular dystrophy
we had a woman that had her thyroid
removed surgically removed and I know
this is difficult even for me to accept
and grew a new thyroid back you know we
have the medical evidence for that so I
don't know any longer what the limit is
I think there's something really cool
happening in the world when
people believe in themselves and when
you believe in yourself you have to
believe in possibility
When You Believe in possibility you have
to believe in yourself so
when somebody
has the opportunity and I think a story
is uh and there's no there's everybody
loves the story there's nothing better
than historian
when someone stands on the stage in
front of 2000 people
and talks about their
journey to heal themselves from a
chronic health condition
and they it's not
um always pretty they lose things they
lose family they sometimes lose their
careers or get sick before they get
better and you see this person's
persistence and you see that they were
not doing the work their inward work to
heal they were doing the work to change
and if they understood if they truly
changed that their biology should change
and they were
uncompromising every day in showing up
for themselves and staying conscious of
their unconscious self and and then
reprogram themselves in some way
and they tell that story it's the four
minute mile it's somebody breaking
through a level of Consciousness or
unconsciousness in the collective
that's observing
the example of Truth
they're actually relating with that
person in a way that causes them to
examine possibility differently
and when you become conscious of a new
possibility a change in Consciousness is
a change in Awareness right so now it's
in the collective and lo and behold it's
not uncommon we just had this happen
in our week-long event in Denver just a
little over a week ago two weeks ago
and we had six people stand up out of a
wheelchair at by the end of the event
now I wasn't expecting that but one uh
person that had Ms in the middle of the
week had a very profound experience very
profound experience
and a professional athlete NFL football
player and um
stood up and you stood up for the
audience and when he stood up he said I
thought I was going to a yoga retreat I
thought my brother was taking me to a
yoga she had no idea what we were doing
here
and then he said I just I just never
loved myself
and it was his act of change that
somehow
changed his health condition he's not
somehow up regulated genes in different
ways suppressed the genes for Ms and
somehow he was more mobile he was
walking by the end of the event and he
was the
magic number one and when everybody saw
that and the crowd the audience was
excited we started seeing other people
have a similar experience now that
possibility is becoming more of a
reality for people
so I always I never limit what could
actually happen but I can tell you that
what an amazing time right now uh to
witness people really uh doing the
uncommon
when you recite to that story I could
see the emotion in your face as you say
it
and I can only imagine with the
information that you have and the
beliefs you have about healing change
transformation
the sense of urgency you must carry and
the sense of like responsibility almost
I guess you must carry
knowing what's possible yeah well um um
it I I do feel responsible for always
keeping the information based in science
and as pure as possible I feel it's
really important to do the research that
we're doing I mean we've we've studied
so much from a scientific standpoint the
process of change in the process of
transformation and what meditation
actually
can do for a person in terms of their
biology and and some of the changes that
we're seeing just in seven days my
responsibility really is to give people
my greatest understanding of the truth
and numerous opportunities to experience
it nothing more you know there's a way
to inspire people into possibility
and so they we combine different models
of science whether it's quantum physics
or Neuroscience or neuroendocrinology or
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection
epigenetics electromagnetism all of
these Sciences allow people to
understand themselves better
and if knowledge is power knowledge
about yourself is self-empowerment you
can Empower people to do something with
it
so the more you understand what you're
doing in the process of change the more
you understand why you're doing it as I
said the how gets easier
so
we now know that if you give people
sound scientific information and that is
the Contemporary language of mysticism
and they can learn that information
they're basically making new circuits in
their brain that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections but if you don't review what
you learn if you don't repeat it it's so
much easier to freak out at than three
members so you got to repeat it over and
over again so
we allow people in our workshops to then
begin to turn and teach it back to
somebody they have to really explain it
if they can't explain it it's not wired
in their brain and they're gonna
Something's Gonna Be left the conjecture
to Superstition to Dogma to spirituality
and and that's something that's not the
result we want we want them to use
science as that model and if they can
explain that model and remind themselves
what they've learned reproduce the same
level of Mind nerve cells that fire
together wire together
so they begin to install the
neurological Hardware in their brain
by teaching others yeah exactly so that
they are prepared for an experience
so then if that information is installed
in their brain that philosophy that
theory uh that knowledge and information
and now they can remember it and they
have that model of understanding
and they understand what they're doing
and why they're doing it if we can set
up the conditions in the environment and
give them the proper instruction
if they can get their behaviors to match
their intentions
they get their actions equal to their
thoughts if they can get their mind and
body working together
they're going to have a new experience
now experience enriches circuitry and
the brightness what experiences does the
moment those neurons begin to string
into place though another part of the
brain makes a chemical and that chemical
is called a feeling or an emotion and
the moment you feel unlimited the moment
you feel grateful the moment you feel
empowered the moment you feel whole
now you're teaching your body chemically
to understand what your mind has
intellectually understood the
information is just not in the brain now
the information now is literally in the
body and now you're embodying the truth
of that knowledge of that philosophy of
that theory
so then you're teaching your body and
instructing your body chemically to
understand what your mind is
intellectually understood
okay so then that information that's
coming as a new experience is changing
your biology in some way and we've
actually shown this
so then if you've done it once
then it means you should be able to do
it again
and the idea is to be able to repeat an
experience and if you can repeat it over
and over again both neurologically and
chemically neurochemically you can
condition your mind and body to begin to
work as one and when you can do it so
many times that your body now knows how
to do it better than your conscious mind
it's innate in you so I want to map out
this process so that I make sure I
understand it
starts with the neurology which I I
heard is uh
a thought which you then ingrain in your
mind by teaching it to someone else is
that accurate well first thing you have
to do is you got to give people
information yeah and science is probably
the closest to the truth in terms of
information
and so when your brain is exposed to
information and you're present and
you're paying attention that neurons
begin to connect that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
the Nobel Prize research candel in the
year 2000 his the researchers said that
if you learned one bit of information
and you paid attention that information
for about an hour
he would double the number of
Connections in your brain as a result of
your interaction with that information
but if you don't review it if you don't
repeat it if you don't think about it
the circuits prune apart right so if
learning is making new synaptic
connections and remembering is
maintaining and sustaining them so it's
so much easier to forget this
information than to remember it so you
learn it once I got a person's head
nodding then they turned the person next
and they only try this out let me try
this out and see if I can repeat it and
so between the two of them they exchange
that information and they start to build
a model of understanding I understand I
got that okay then we advance the
informational but more and they they're
adding new Stitches into the
three-dimensional tapestry of their gray
matter and they have to remind
themselves what they've learned
reproduce that same level of Mind mind
is the brain in action
as you install those neurological
circuits in your brain then now you're
prepared it's the Forerunner to the
experience you're prepared for the
experience so give the proper
instruction get your body involved get
involved in the process the experience
then causes circuits to become more
enriched that's what experience does and
then it makes a chemical and a chemical
is called a feeling or an emotion and
the stronger the emotion you feel from
the experience the more you remember it
and what is that experience
abundance Health wholeness a mystical
experience success a new relationship a
new career
um
a new life
whatever the person's whatever whatever
that Vision that person wants to arrive
at in the future and to actually go from
the thought of that Vision to the actual
experience of it and the distance
between that thought and that experience
is called time
so if we can teach people to shorten the
distance between the thought of what
they want and the experience of having
it then they start believing more that
they're the creator of their life
what would you say to somebody that
doesn't think thoughts matter that much
I would say 95 of the World Plus or
maybe more 99 of the World Plus sees
thoughts as something that we are
you know it's my head talking it's me
talking in my head and as long as I
don't act on those thoughts they're
inconsequential
I would I would say then that's the
truth
is it the truth I don't know but for me
my thoughts do matter I think every
thought that you have makes a chemical
and you can have thoughts that make you
feel good and thoughts that make you
feel bad
and and I think that if 90 percent
of the thoughts that we think are the
same thoughts as the day before the same
thoughts lead to the same choices the
same choices lead to the same behaviors
the same behaviors will create the same
experiences and the same experiences
produce the very same emotions and those
same emotions influence a person's very
same thoughts and their biology their
neuroscircuitry their neurochemistry
their hormones and even their gene
expression stays the same because
they're staying the same there's nothing
wrong with that
but I do think that if you think
differently and you learn new
information and you have new thoughts if
you can make new choices and demonstrate
new behaviors and create new experiences
and arrive at new goals and feel new
emotions I would say that's evolution
and I think that people really really
secretly believe in themselves on some
level and and I think being defined by a
vision of the future or really always
always dreaming of another great
experience I think is a great reason to
wake up in the morning
I've had lots of conversations with very
smart people on this podcast from
multiple disciplines you know
psychiatrists psychologists athletes
Health practitioners and they've given
me such great advice on which is
irrefutable scientific advice from so
many areas of my life and for some
reason there's still areas of my life
that I still can't act upon that advice
and I think probably for most of my
listeners who've heard great advice on
this podcast and they think yes that's
who I want to be I have an intention to
stop eating sugar at 1am at night or I
have an intention to become organized or
to be this kind of friend or partner
they have the information right what
there's something stood in the way of me
doing something about that information
on a regular basis yeah
well I can give you a few answers for
that unfortunately
it normally takes crisis trauma disease
diagnosis betrayal loss a person has to
reach that lowest denominator
where nothing's making that feeling go
away has to well not they don't have to
but this is human this is The Human
Condition this is the moment where they
don't feel like returning the texts they
don't feel like going to dinner and
seeing the same people they don't feel
like
um
watching the same television show any
longer the sports car the Wardrobe the
none of that is making this feeling go
away this is a moment of Reckoning for
the soul
and this is really when you could
actually see yourself
Through The Eyes of someone else because
you don't feel like yourself anymore and
that's the moment where people begin to
change they can see how they've been
thinking they can notice how they've
been acting they could pay attention or
become aware of how they've been feeling
for the last 20 years and that that idea
in in Neuroscience is called
metacognition that's the moment you're
no longer the program now what we
believe and what we've seen and what I
think is much better approach is
um being defined by a vision of the
future and if you understood
that you could actually elevate your
state without anyone or anything every
single day and hold whatever that
intention of your future is and it takes
a coherent brain to do that
and feel the emotion of your future
before it happens
that is you know you can't wait for your
wealth to feel success you can't or
abundance you can't wait for your new
relationship to feel love you can't wait
for the mystical experience to feel all
or your healing to feel whole or
grateful that's kind of the old model of
reality of cause and effect waiting for
something out there
to change to take away this emptiness
this lack that I feel in here
if you teach people then they could
Elevate their state and we teach that
model through meditation
and they can combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
teach them how to make that heart of
theirs more coherent
if they do that properly then they'll
live their life feeling like
their future has already happened now
from that elevated State instead of that
self-limited state they can become as
conscious
of that unconscious self as they could
if they were at that limited State and
and being defined by that vision of the
future
getting up every day inspired by it and
not letting any person any circumstance
anything in our life remove us from that
Vision that would be a day well lived so
then most people then they have that
vision of the future
but they give up on that Vision because
in order for them to arrive at that
Vision they have to do something they
have to think differently they have to
act differently they have to feel
differently
and it's so much easier to make the same
Choice every single day and the hardest
part
about change is not making the same
Choice as you did the day before
and the moment you decide to make a
different Choice you're going to feel
uncomfortable because you're stepping
from the known into the unknown
so some people rather cling to their
self-pity
then take a chance and possibility
they'd rather tell the story of their
past
instead of telling the story of their
future they'd rather believe in their
past instead of believe in their future
it's so much more important though to
romance your future instead of romance
your past and I think if people
understood that they could actually
arrive at it
I think many people have done this
already in their life I think everybody
at least once in their life has done
something great and when they did
something great they just made up their
mind and they made a decision in that
moment to do something or to change with
such firm intention
but the amplitude of energy in making
that choice caused their body to respond
to their mind
that the choice that they were making to
change became a moment in time that they
would never forget
and the stronger the emotion they felt
in order to change the more they
remembered the choice
and we could say then that they're
giving their body a taste
of the future emotionally and they're
literally aligning to that destiny
we discovered that if you keep doing
that every day
somehow you'll arrive at that Destiny in
your biology will literally begin to
change to look like you're living in a
different life
what are some of the biggest myths
relating to behavior change and
I guess character and personality change
um that hold people back
I'll probably belief
I think and so many ways that a belief
is a unconscious process a belief is a
thought you keep thinking over and over
again until it's hardwired in your brain
and most beliefs are based on past
experiences
and so many people have a belief about
something that has to change in order
for them to arrive at a new place in
their life
and what we discovered a lot of times
with people in this work is that
they they when they say for example they
were healing themselves of a health
condition
sometimes they would
do their meditations three times in one
day and I asked them why three times and
they said because I stopped believing
and when I caught myself no longer
believing in it I had to sit down and
change my belief again
in other words they had to get up
believing more in their future instead
of believing Less in it and they have to
change their state of being to do that
so I think that that's a limitation I
also think that unconsciously we're
always waiting for something out there
in our life to change so that we can
change or feel the relief of the lack of
what we don't have
and I do think that's kind of a limited
model of reality I think when you start
changing inside of you and you start
seeing the changes happening outside of
you you go from being a victim in your
life to being a creator of your life and
and I think that when that occurs
then all of a sudden it's no longer a
have to
it's something that you want to do you
don't you actually don't want the magic
to end in your life so now you become a
work in progress by investing in
yourself
when you invest in yourself you invest
in your future
so there's probably a chronic disbelief
that many of us have that we're not
creators of our life and the only one we
get the parking space or something good
happens to us do we believe that we're
the creator of our life but imagine a
world where everybody actually took
responsibility in being the creator of
their life and no longer the victim of
their life I think we would see a
dramatic shift in Consciousness that
makes people feel uncomfortable this
idea of personal responsibility it's
quite a it's almost become quite a
controversial controversial idea
the idea that we are the creator of Our
Lives because then I have to accept
responsibility for all the bad things
that happened Dave dumped me I got fired
from work
uh someone bumped into my car and it
hurt my neck
well maybe maybe that happened by
default
maybe that happened by not creating
maybe you were just left to the
randomness
of reality that
that maybe you're not creating
and the fact that you're not creating
your your left to the effects of your
environment actually controlling you
controlling your feelings and thoughts
and by creating what you mean by
creating isn't well well it's being
intentional if you woke up every morning
and you truly made time to think like
this okay
if my personality creates my personal
reality
and my personality is made of how I
think
how I act and how I feel
if I want to create a new personal
reality a new life
I'm going to have to change my
personality
and most people try to create a new
reality a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work we
literally have to become someone else so
if you said okay
let me not default
and go unconscious to that 95 percent of
who I am that's programmed let me become
so conscious of the way I think and
become so aware of how I'm going to act
today let me decide what emotions keep
me connected to my past and bring me to
a lower level a lower level of energy
let me not
go unconscious
and then if you said okay
the belief is just a thought I keep
thinking over and over again what
thoughts do I want to fire and wire in
my brain and with attention and with
intention
to begin to familiarize yourself with a
new way of thinking meditation means to
become familiar with
if you keep firing and wiring those
circuits you're going to begin to
install the hardware repeated enough
times and it becomes a software program
that could be the new voice in your head
that says I can it is possible
if you said okay
when did I fall from grace yesterday
when did I when did I lose it oh my gosh
it was with at work with my co-workers
with my ex with my enemy with the news
with traffic
acting this way is not going to make me
happy
if I had another opportunity another
opportunity how would I do it
if you could close your eyes and
rehearse in your mind mentally how
you're going to behave in certain
situations
I'll give you a specific one anyone so
I'll give you the specific one where
late at night on occasion I've eaten
things that I really regret eating also
another one that I'm trying to work hard
on is I can be very messy
with when I travel so my my hotel room
can look like a mess and I don't like
that about myself and I don't know why I
do it but it's almost like you talk
about being unconscious I'm clearly not
thinking about it but that's part of the
problem and it's the same with the
bloody sugar at midnight
eating ordering things that are
and then feeling instant guilt 10
seconds after I've put it in my mouth
well
it may be that on some level
well you could actually be addicted to
the guilt not to the sugar
and so you you return to the same
emotional state
that allows that action to reoccur so if
you said let me decide how I am going to
act what I'm not going to do and you
rehearsed it the research on mental
rehearsal says your brain will look like
you already did it that you'll be so
present the brain won't know the
difference between what you're imagining
and what is real the brain will begin to
change to look like the experience has
already happened now
you're priming your brain for that
behavior keep rehearsing it rehearsing
at house I can well
mentally mentally rehearsing mental
rehearsal is one of these great ideas in
Neuroscience where you can actually
install circuits in your brain right so
everybody has done this musicians do it
they're playing a song in their mind all
the time athletes do it they're always
going over their moves dancers do it
actors do it so many people rehearse
mentally what they're about to do and
when they do that they actually Prime
their brain they actually can change
their brain
and change their body just by thought
alone physiologically changing
physiologically changed you can take a
group of people
that never played the piano before and
divide them into two different groups
and do functional brain scans on both
groups one group
they'll come for two hours a day for
five days and they'll practice these
one-handed scales and chords now you
learn something new you make new
Connections in your brain you get some
instruction you get your body involved
when you get your own body involved
you're going to have an experience you
pay attention to what you're doing and
you repeat it over and over again nerve
cells that fire together wire together
you're going to begin to install new
circuits in the opposite side of your
brain that's that's common
you do the scan at the end you see those
actual physical changes you take those
people the other group and you ask them
to close their eyes without lifting a
finger
have the mental rehearse those scales
and cores and at the end of five days
they grow the same amount of circuits in
their brain as the people who actually
physically demonstrated the act in other
words they were so present with what
they were doing
the brain did not know the difference
between the real life experience and
what they were Imagining the brain was
physically changing to look like they
already experienced it they already did
it
so now you take those people
never played the piano before they've
just been mentally rehearsing for two
hours a day for five days you set them
in front of a piano and they could
actually play those scales and chords
why because they primed their brain for
that behavior
so then if you're gonna prime your brain
for a new Behavior whether you're the
CEO of a company
whether you're a parent
whether you're learning something the
more you rehearse it mentally the more
you prime your brain and body for the
act so you could actually practice
rehearsing how you're going to change in
your life and if you keep doing it
enough times your behaviors will match
your intentions automatically because
you have the Mind installed to do it if
you don't have the Mind installed to do
it you'll go back to the same past
Behavior so I play through that scenario
of making the decision differently
exactly and rehearse it in your mind
until it feels right until you feel like
I could actually do that and go from
start to finish without losing your
attention
and so that it gets easier each time you
do it it makes sense then you're you'll
you'll actually do it and then if you
said okay
enough of this guilt I've I've felt
enough of it I don't like feeling that
way I could actually
break the conditioning of that emotion
in my body can I
condition my body can I teach my body to
feel something differently what would be
the feeling that I want to feel if I was
able to do it would it be worth would it
be self-love would it be Freedom would
it be Joy let me teach my body
emotionally what a future could actually
feel like before it happens if you keep
doing it over and over again you're
going to start making more of those
chemicals and it's become easier for you
to do it it's going to become familiar
to you and that's exactly what
meditation is to become familiar with an
old self to know thyself become so
conscious of that unconscious self that
you don't go unconscious to that self
and how many times do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain let me become familiar with
those what behaviors do I want to
demonstrate what would greatness do what
would love do
and actually rehearse a greater a
greater way rehearse it enough times so
that you could actually step into that
footprint teach your body emotionally
that there's another way to feel and do
it over and over again it'll become
familiar to you and so the model of
change is unlearning and relearning
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self it's pruning
synaptic connections and sprouting new
connections it's unfiring and unwiring
re-firing and rewiring deprogramming and
reprogramming losing your mind and
creating a new one unmerizing emotions
that have been stored in the body and
then reconditioning the body to a new
mind to a new emotion turns out if you
teach people how to do that
in seven days you can see very profound
biological changes if they immerse
themselves into the experience and what
do these biological changes look like
well so we run week-long events around
the world and I think it's so important
to do events in person with community
because it's a flock it's a herd it's a
school it's a collective
and so that exact process in seven days
so we take people through a very
immersive experience and we do
functional brain scans or fmris or
quantitative eegs before they start the
event and then we at the end of seven
days we look at their brains at the end
of seven days and there are dramatic
changes in the way their brain works
very significant changes some of them
are really outstanding changes we put
teach people how to create more hard
coherence when you feel anger when you
feel frustration when you feel
impatience when you feel resentment your
heart beats out of order when you feel
gratitude when you have kindness and
care
You Feel Love For Life your heart beats
in a more orderly fashion you can
actually train somebody to get good at
feeling that way and we we use that and
we see people at the end of seven days
be able to regulate their heart much
better and it's a function of really how
soon or how slow we age
we take blood and we measure
2882 different metabolites in in a
person's blood and at the end of seven
days we measure again and
I can tell you that if you're a novice
meditator
really never meditated before kind of
your first event
and you go through that seven day
process at the end of seven days there
are so many biological changes that are
taking place in the collective in the
community not just one not just two the
majority of people and I mean a
significant majority of people
suggesting that their body literally is
living in a new environment in a new
life and there are chemicals in their
bloodstream in terms of information
it wasn't there prior to the event in
other words
some way without taking any drug without
any taking an exogenous substance
without changing their diet without
changing their lifestyle in any other
way except going through this process
eating the same foods that they
typically eat
that at the end of seven days there's
chemistry there's biology that suggests
that somehow their biology is changing
significantly
we measure gene expression I can tell
you that you can change your gene
expression in seven days we measure the
microbiome and once again seven days
there are dramatic changes
in the microbiome and the mind somehow
is making significant and effective
changes in our in our body so our
research is pretty outstanding because
um a seven day intervention
that's producing these effects there's
there's not a whole lot of drugs that
that are as effective
and we've discovered that
the nervous system makes a pharmacy of
chemicals right now that works better
than any drug that's what we've
discovered and it's all within you
foreign
I am a fixer
in my friendship groups and what I mean
by that is I'm someone who probably over
involves in themselves in trying to help
friends change stuff which is a gift in
a curse often times occurs
but um I often get because I love
someone and they're close to me and I
want the best for them when when I see
that they are experiencing a recurring
pattern of behavior or habit um that is
causing them unhappiness loneliness to
miss the goals they have in their life
of becoming a you know a husband or a
wife or a partner or whatever it might
be I have a growing sense of um
frustration
because and I and that sometimes exerts
it it's that sometimes manifests itself
is trying to you know fix and help and
give advice and change them you must
experience
that in a different way you're much
smarter than me you must experience that
in a different way when you meet people
that you can see her having these
recurring patterns of behavior and when
you see that in them
has there any has there any ever been
frustration on your part have you ever
been frustrated that change hasn't
happened in someone that you loved you
know I think it's I think it's such a
noble act to change and I and I
understand how hard it is to change
I understand that process so
I think the greatest thing that I could
ever do for someone is to show them what
change looks like it's so much more
profound than anything that I could ever
say
um
and I would never offer my opinion to
them I would love them unconditionally
because I maybe see a part of myself
that I've changed and I understand how
hard it is to change or or I understand
that they'll they're going to have their
moment when they're ready that's a
change and so I think it's I think it's
really interesting because what I've
learned over the years is that no new
information
can enter the nervous system that's not
equal to the person's emotional state
you can give them
the answer the right answer to the
problem and they won't hear it because
it's not relevant equal to the emotion
that they're experiencing
what we've learned is a
if you think people in you just say
seven days just cross the river of
change go from the old self to the new
self immerse yourself fully into it
break free from the chains of those
emotions that keep you anchored to the
Past overcome those habits and behaviors
that keep you programmed into a
predictable future overcome
um all those aspects of your beliefs
that keep you stuck in a certain state
in terms of how you're thinking in those
hardwired perceptions seven days break
free and and normally the person has the
answer to their own question I think
that's when it becomes really relevant
when you have your own Insight your own
Epiphany when it's your own truth
because you've you've worked to get
Beyond it
people when they analyze themselves or
analyze their life within some
disturbing emotion when we looked at the
real-time brain scans we saw that they
were actually making the brain worse
we're driving their brain further out of
balance overthinking over analyzing uh
and so
when you analyze something within an
emotion an emotion is a is a record of
the past so you're thinking in the past
the solution could never be there free
the person from that emotion and of
course they they see they they see it
from a greater level of consciousness
for all those people listening right now
that are like me that try and fix
because of through I mean through what
they think of as love I may maybe be I'm
doing it for other reasons but
what what could they do to be a better
ally or friend or partner to that
individual but based on everything
you've said that maybe they need their
own moment or you know their emotional
system isn't in regulation with their
information God anytime we we don't do
anybody a great service is to help them
out of their emotional state I mean it's
not a lecture that's going to help them
come on let's go do something come on
let's go just get them doing something
just breaking themselves out of that
state it's not like the answer it's they
they have to change their state to get
the answer so
if I were to do anything
I would want to help them shorten their
emotional reaction to get them get
beyond the emotion whatever that is and
I wouldn't be a lecturer would be
something fun that we did or something
unusual that we did or just trying
something just let's just do something
and I think I think showing people what
what what love looks like show them what
Joy looks like show them what happiness
looks like I think I think people notice
that I think I think they pay attention
to that it gives them permission
to do the same
so
um maybe just show up as
the person you would want to be around
if you were feeling that way
when you look at the state of the world
at the moment and the direction of
travel the trajectory of you know
technology and the way we're living our
lives and the decisions we're making at
a collective level
what are the things that most concern
you
well I always ask myself is it getting
better is it getting worse you know and
I I think
um
in my lifetime I don't think I've ever
experienced the world
as it is today just with so many
variations of so many things
and I question the information that I'm
receiving
and I think that we need some type of
intervention as a species we need we we
need a change we need an intervention in
some way
question the information you're
receiving from where and what kind of
Infamous intervention are you suggesting
I just don't know the information that I
that I am exposed to or information that
people are exposed to is the truth I
just questioned that these days and and
because you can you get so many you get
so many degrees of it and so many uh and
I and I don't know if it's
based in altruism you know for the for
the goodness of human beings or or for
self-interests and I and I think that's
a I think people are waking up more to
the understanding that something
has to change you know for us to really
survive as a species
and what are the symptoms of
the cultural disease that you're talking
about what are they
a lack of connection
uh you know you know we're in 3D reality
you know connecting communing
cooperating uh
creating I think those are things that
um
I think if you keep people in survival
and you keep them in fear and you keep
them at War and you keep them angry and
you keep them in pain and you keep them
confused and you can control their
attention
um by controlling their emotions
um
I think I think um we're gonna you know
we may not make it you know as as a
species
but I think that when people Truly Come
Together in in in an elevated State I
think it's Collective networks of
observers that determine reality
and I don't think it's the number of
people I think it's the most coherent in
heart and brain that begin to produce
effects so the coming of
a new Consciousness has to be a
collective it's not one person
it's a collective group of people and
and I believe that you get enough people
collectively coming together that we can
hopefully uh
steer it in a different direction
hopefully yeah
how about you
are you optimistic I am I'm optimistic
because I think people by Nature
are good
I think there's goodness in human beings
and I have the privilege of traveling
around the world and I see that and it
transcends countries and cultures and
races and gender transcends diet it
transcends all that stuff uh it's just
when people are happy with themselves
and in love with life
um I think I think their natural
tendency is to give and I think we're
wired to do that when we're not in
survival
when we're not in survival when you use
this word survival
are you talking about the the fight or
flight state that we um many of us live
in yeah I would say I would say that
living in stress is living in survival
and stress is when your brain body are
knocked out of homeostasis
stress is when your brain and body are
knocked out of balance the stress
response is what the body innately does
to return itself back to balance
the problem is is that if you keep
turning on that fight-or-flight system
you keep turning on that emergency
system
you'll actually cause people to stay out
of balance and that imbalance becomes
the new balance and they're headed for
some type of disease some type of
breakdown no organism can tolerate
emergency mode for an extended period of
time and when you're in survival and
that primitive system is switched on
it's really about the self when you're
in survival you have to take care of
yourself so
um the emotions of anger and hostility
and aggression and competition and
frustration and resentment
and envy and jealousy and insecurity and
fear and anxiety and hopelessness and
powerlessness and depression and pain
and suffering guilt and shame are all
derived
from the hormones of stress and
psychology calls them normal human
States Of Consciousness those are
Altered States Of Consciousness and when
we're in that state when we're living in
survival
we experience separation we we divide in
in a lot of ways and so there's biology
that goes along with that and the
hormones of stress heighten the senses
and cause us to become materialists and
and now when we're in lack or separation
we force outcomes we control outcomes we
fight for outcomes we compete for
outcomes we manipulate outcomes in a lot
of ways we we turn into a more of a
primitive self so
hard
um
to change that especially when you don't
have enough money
or you just lost your job or you just
ended a relationship or
your best friend past it's really hard
to move Beyond those emotional states
and so I think that that teaching people
um how to change those emotional states
and move out of those are really
important and
um
75 to 90 percent of every person that
goes to a health care facility in the
Western World goes in because of
psychological or emotional stress that's
eight or nine out of ten
and emotional stress and psychological
stress are the ones that tend to be the
most harmful because if it's not T-Rex
that's chasing you but it's your
co-worker in the next cubicle what was
once very adaptive becomes very
maladaptive and and the rush of those
adrenal hormones
become kind of addictive to people
and they use the problems they use the
conditions in their life to reaffirm
their addiction to that emotion they
need their enemy to feel hatred and and
if their enemy died they'd they'd still
feel hatred or they'd find another one
they need the bad relationship they need
the bad job in order to feel and that's
why it's hard to change and people
become addicted to the life they don't
even like
and so if you can turn on the stress
response just by thought Alone by
thinking about your problems then that's
the truth you can become addicted to
your own thoughts
and if the long-term effects of the
hormones of stress push the genetic
buttons that create disease your
thoughts could make you sick
and then the question is if your
thoughts could make you sick and your
thoughts make you well and we're
actually discovering that that's
absolutely possible
so then
teaching people then a little bit about
how to manage their emotional state and
to self-regulate I think is a great gift
for people because when they begin to
break an addiction to any emotion or the
conditioning of any emotion there's
going to be Cravings that go on just
like uh just like any addict there you
know and and you've many people overdose
and many people have bad trips and and
so when they start changing and the
body's craving uh those familiar
emotions the body starts signaling the
brain you know of memories or to think
certain ways and to make certain choices
do certain things crave certain
experiences just to feel that same
emotion and people say well
this feels right I know that feels
familiar that really feels familiar and
and many people will tell the story
of why they feel that way based on some
past experience and it's usually not in
the recent past it's usually many years
ago like a toxic relationship or
whatever that is and so
they're basically saying I had an event
in my life and since that event I'm
still living by the same emotion and I
haven't been able to change
and they'll tell the story of that past
in in Psychology the latest research on
memory shows that 50 of that story isn't
even the truth
they're they're they're making it up
because they don't have the same
brainless they had then and so then
people people are reliving a miserable
life they never even had just to excuse
themselves from changing
and they embellish the stories so that
it sounds really hard to change
so what is it what is that point then
for a person when they say
the only person
that this emotion of hatred or anger or
frustration or resentment the only
person that this is hurting is me
because those those chemicals are down
regulating genes and creating disease
and a person finally really realizes
that and they really decide to change
when they overcome the emotion
the memory without the emotion is called
wisdom and that's the name of the game
in three-dimensional reality now they're
ready for a new experience
it's not it's not reliving the past you
don't need to you don't need to talk
about all you need to do is overcome the
emotion when you overcome the emotion
you're free from the past you can see it
from a greater level of Consciousness
and that's when a person so many times
and when they truly change they'll say
this we've seen it over and over again
they reached that point where they
finally break through and they and some
of them have had some really difficult
past they'll say I would not want to
change one thing in my past because it
brought me to this moment that's the
moment to pass no longer exists and they
can look at their betrayers
and see where it all had to happen for
that moment and now they're they're free
they they no longer belong to the past
they belong to the Future
I've never heard the concept or idea of
being addicted to a negative emotion
people talk to me about being addicted
to dopamine and pleasure and you know
and all those things in you know like
masturbation and
sugar and but the thought of being
addicted to a negative emotion is what
you said to me earlier about the guilt
well think about this
what do people do when they when they
feel an emotion what do they do they
rely on something outside of them
to make that emotion go away so whether
it's the masturbation or the pornography
or the gambling or the shopping or the
sugar or the whatever it's all because
they're trying to make that feeling go
away and they're using something outside
of them so then there is some emotion
that the person is regulating that's why
they're doing that they're doing that
right so so change the emotional state
and it makes sense then the need to do
it diminishes
which is not
doesn't seem to be very easy to do
change my emotional state well again I
think
um
if you if you understood
what you were doing and why you were
doing it just like learning anything if
you if you understood a formula I think
it wouldn't be as hard as you think it
is I mean because there is a way to
change
and step one in that process of change
is new information always it's the
Forerunner to any experience
without the information we doubt
that it's possible
and again that the information in the
science removes the doubt
I was doing some research recently about
um why people change their beliefs and
why they don't change their beliefs and
some beliefs they're more susceptible to
take on some information they're more
they're susceptible to take on one of
the things I read about was when they
believed the source another thing I read
about was when they when it's good news
so in studies where they say to someone
you're more attractive according to the
public than you believed they're likely
to shift rather than finding out they're
less attractive and also things like
Health you're more healthy than you
thought you were genetically they're
more likely to shift a belief the nature
of our beliefs and the nature of belief
change
um I I was writing in in my book about
how
um looking in the mirror and telling
yourself something you like some of the
sort of modern day manifestation
Community believe doesn't seem to work
just looking in the mirror and telling
myself that I'm beautiful and Rich and
successful and Powerful doesn't seem to
be an effective way to cause actual
belief change
do you agree or disagree with this idea
that you can look in the mirror and say
something to yourself
when when we study belief and the change
in belief
I'll answer it on two levels Stephen the
first level is that in order for a
person to change a belief or perception
about themselves in their life
the majority of those people made a
decision with such firm intention that
the amplitude of that decision carried a
level of energy that was greater than
the hardwired programs in the brain and
the emotional conditioning their body as
I said earlier their body literally
responded to their mind the choice that
they were making became a moment in time
they would never forget they'll tell you
where they were what time of day it was
who they were with when they made up
their mind to change it became a
long-term memory and the stronger the
emotion we feel the more altered we are
inside of us the more we remember that
choice that's why we need pain sometimes
that's when you said when you painted
yourself into a corner and you said this
is it
I don't care how I feel body
I don't care how long it takes time I
don't care what people think I don't
care what's going on in my life
environment I'm gonna do this and you
made up your mind the moment you felt
that emotion you were aligning to a new
future and to change
is to be greater than your body to be
greater than your environment and to be
greater than time
and so
when a person comes out of the resting
state
because your body is trillions of cells
70 trillion cells and they're all spying
on your brain and if you were sitting
there and and you said nine out of ten
times I'm gonna fake standing up one
time I'm actually going to stand up
before you ever made that conscious
decision your body is so precognitive it
already knows when you're going to stand
up because it's got to release a certain
amount of adrenaline so the same volume
of your blood goes to your brain
so if you're sitting on the couch with
the remote control and you got your cell
phone here and your iPad here and your
computer here and your dog here and your
beer here and the big TV there and
you're eating your popcorn and and you
say you know I I think um
I'm gonna change tomorrow
what do you think your precognitive body
is going to say relax he's lying again
he's not he's not willing to he's not
willing to Signal the body it's time to
ride you know it's not there's no signal
to the body
and so making that choice to change your
state of being with a clear intention
and elevated emotion actually changes
your state to believe in that future
more than you believe in your past keep
it up keep doing it that's a big
explosion in the field that's important
that's a change in energy and nobody
changes until they change their energy
and when they change their energy they
change their life so then you make up
your mind to do that and all of a sudden
you have that synchronicity you have
that Serendipity you have that
coincidence and all of a sudden you're
saying hey that worked something I did
inside of me produced an effect outside
of me I'm going to pay attention to what
I did I'm gonna do it again let's try it
again let's the experiment continue you
do it again and then you say Well when
did I stop disbelieving oh my God I will
stop disbelieving when I ran into that
person we had that conversation and oh
my God I I returned back to my old
belief again okay next time that happens
I'm gonna this is what I'll do you
rehearse it in so your evolution
in your belief in self it changes as
well so then
so many people second point will
actually say this you know I read the
philosophy I understand the knowledge I
understand what it means to change I
understand the power of meditation I saw
the testimonials I saw people heal I
believe it's the truth
I just didn't believe it could work for
me this is a big moment this is a moment
where you step out of the bleachers and
you got to get on the playing field
that's the person who says if this works
and I believe it it works I gotta prove
it to myself I gotta actually I gotta
actually prove it to myself that I
believe that it could work for me
and some of them show up every day for a
year and never miss their work never
miss their meditation a whole year and
changing from the old self to the new
self they were doing their meditations
to change not to heal they were doing
their meditations to change them when
they changed they healed they did their
meditation sometimes three times a day
because they stopped believing they
start disbelieving and they were like I
defaulted why because I'm feeling the
emotion of my past some stray thought
some response to someone or something
caused me to feel and I forgot I'm back
to the emotion that's familiar and I
can't believe in that future I'm
believing in my past let me sit down and
change my state of being again and get
up believing in my future again and
sometimes they had to do it three times
in one day and when they understood
that's the environment that signals the
gene that's epigenetics and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion and it is
you could actually signal genes ahead of
the environment by changing your
emotional state they were doing it with
that intention
and when he was signed meaning to the
ACT you get a greater outcome and you
turn on the prefrontal cortex and now
your biology literally begins to change
and we have data that suggests by just
having the intention to make certain
genes
to make certain proteins or signal
certain genes and make certain proteins
just having the intention literally
begins to cause the body to make those
chemicals
and what causes relapse in those moments
because I've had multiple moments where
I thought Behavior change had been
established and I managed to conduct a
new habit cycle and new Behavior
favorable you know intended behavior for
a period and then something happens in
my life
almost subconsciously seamlessly
seamlessly and I'm back yeah to all the
old circuitry you went unconscious you
weren't unconscious and normally
it's unconscious to some thought
or some response
in your environment you see someone or
you do something or you have some
interaction in your outer world and the
moment you have that interaction you
caught it causes you to feel a certain
way and you return back
to us to the Past basically the emotion
is the past and that the body is
actually living in the past it's so
objective it doesn't know the difference
doesn't know the difference between the
real life experience that's creating
that emotion and the emotion that
person's living by every day it's
believing it's in the same past
experience again and it will behave in
the past and it will think in the past
subconsciously subconsciously seamlessly
so I could for example if going to
I don't know let's say France I had a
traumatic experience in France when I
was 10 years old let's just say and then
I go to France when I'm 30 years old and
I get back I just start eating junk food
for example
and I don't know why I've like fallen
out of my gym habit and I'm eating junk
food that theoretically that could be my
subconscious that
um
falling back into a is experiencing that
survival without me knowing knowing it
yes so so if to change is to be greater
than your environment to be greater than
your body and to be greater than time
then your neocortex your thinking brain
is a reflection of everything you know
in your life it's an artifact of the
past it's a record repository of
everything you've learned and
experienced to this date and you have a
neurological Network for everything
known in your environment your parents
your friends your car your computer
every object every person everything you
have a neurological Network for your
identity as your body from your past
your Ambitions and your future your
brain is a reflection of everything
that's known
and because you've experienced all these
elements in your environment there's an
emotion associated with it so you have
an emotion associated with certain
people it's different emotions
associated with other people different
emotions associated with other objects
and things and other places in time
so then
there's so much research to show that
when you put a person in the same
environment and they see the same people
and they go to the same places and they
do the same things at their exact same
time it's no longer their personalities
creating their personal reality their
personal reality is creating their
personality their environment is
controlling unconsciously or
subconsciously the way they're thinking
and the way they're feeling so when they
see their co-worker when they see their
friend when they see their parents
they're seeing their parents their
friends their co-workers in the
neurological Network as a memory of the
past
and because every one of those people
has an emotion associated with it they
start feeling the emotion that's
connected to them and now their state of
being then is returning back to the past
so then to change then is to be greater
than your environment to think act and
feel differently in the same conditions
in your life that's called change
how does how would I do that wake from
you know
I walk in I see my parents
mum dad dog house I grew up in is there
something that I do in that moment
before that moment when I woke up that
morning to make sure that I didn't slip
off into the unconscious
um memory and then for therefore get the
sort of unconscious feelings about
that experience well whatever it is that
you want if it's if it's overreading I
don't know I'm making stuff up if it's
some emotional button that you have with
your family and you don't want to feel
that way yeah I would rehearse that if
if I didn't want to have that if if you
have a great if you're I mean I go to
when I would go to my parents home when
I when I got older it was all most of
the associations were so fond for me
just being at home and being with my
parents and remembering where I grew up
it was always fun for me and and coming
back and see how much I changed in
coming back and seeing the life that I
lived at one point you know one point in
my timeline
so if it's something that you truly want
to change you're going to remind
yourself
how you're not going to think you're
going to you're going to remind yourself
how you're not going to act you're going
to remind yourself how you're not going
to feel and you gotta remind yourself
enough time so you don't forget because
the moment you forget you go unconscious
then you're gonna remind yourself how
you are going to think you remind
yourself what you're going to do and
rehearse it in your mind and you're
going to remind yourself what feeling
you want to stay in the entire time so
you don't default back to the old self
if you practice that I guarantee you
you'll make some progress if you lose it
nothing wrong tomorrow's another day
another you got another chance and we
just get really good at whatever we
practice so then when you return back
into your life and you say okay
no person
no place no thing No Object no
circumstance no pain no craving
is going to cause me to move from the
state today I guarantee you if you're
able to maintain that modified State of
Mind and Body your entire day something
unusual happen and will come in a way
that you least expect
that surprises you and leaves no doubt
that what you're doing inside of you is
producing some effect outside of you and
the moment you see the feedback in your
environment as a result of your internal
change you're going to pay attention and
do it again and you're going to start
believing God did I really create that
did that really happen because of how I
changed that's when the game really
begins to become exciting practice
I've been at it a long time
I can tell
practice yeah um people hear that they
go Joe how long how much practice
you know are you talking about uh I've
got I've got to do this for three four
five years or you know and and that
practice what does that look like
practically
for someone like me who hears everything
you've just said and wants to make
changes and cures of my life okay so
there's two times when the door to the
subconscious mind opens up when you wake
up in the morning because your brain
waves are going from Dell to the Theta
to Alpha to Beta when you go to bed at
night you go from beta to Alpha Theta to
Delta and you slip through that scale
pretty quickly in the morning in the
evening but your brain waves start to
change during those times and and one of
the features one of the important
elements of meditation is to get beyond
the analytical mind and what separates
the conscious mind from the subconscious
mind is the analytical mind so five
percent as we said is our conscious mind
95 percent is programmed subconsciously
and if you're going to try to change
yourself with your conscious mind you're
outside the operating system
so then you got to learn how to change
your brain waves slow them down
get beyond the analytical mind and enter
the operating system where you can
rewrite a program where you can make
those changes and so
learn how to do that practice learn how
to do that
and again it's not a big deal it's easy
to learn
and then once you can slow your brain
waves down in your more suggestible to
what you're thinking now you can
reprogram you can't do with your
conscious mind you can say I'm healthy
I'm healthy I'm wealthy I'm wealthy I'm
unlimited I'm unlimited I'm happy I'm
happy I'm whole on whole and your body's
saying no you're not dude you're
miserable you're unhappy that thought
never makes it past the brain stem to
reach the body right so
it's important for us to in the morning
or the evening instead of reaching for
our cell phone as the first thing as a
habit that we do in checking our texts
and our WhatsApp and our Telegram and
our social media and our Instagram and
our Twitter and and Facebook whenever
else people do their emails they get
connected to everything known in their
life before you start that try this out
as an experiment before you start your
day instead of falling into that
redundant habit you know go on autopilot
just say okay if the change is to be
greater than my body to be greater than
my environment be greater than time and
and the environment's so seductive and
my body's craving certain emotions and
it's programmed to get up and do things
I'm going to sit my body down I'm gonna
tame the animal here and when I'm ready
to get up we're going to get up not when
it's tired or when it wants to go
you could literally go Inward and forget
about your outer world no longer think
about anything out there
if you could lose track of the familiar
past or the predictable future and fall
into the present moment and if you were
sitting there in silence aware of
nothing but you and you said okay what
is the greatest expression of myself I
can be today
and do that exact process let me write
down two thoughts that are not going to
slip by my awareness unnoticed by me
today two memories whatever it is
what are two behaviors I want to change
today let me stay conscious of them and
not go unconscious to them today even if
it means how I speak
what are two emotions that I live by
every day that I can literally change I
want to become conscious of what they
feel like in my body I want to catch
them the moment I start feeling them and
review them over and over again enough
times so I don't go unconscious okay now
I'm conscious of my unconscious that 95
percent how do I want to think how would
greatness think today let me review it
let me repeat let me remember how I am
going to think let me remember how I am
going to think me remember how I'm going
to behave here how am I going to act
here let me rehearse a change I want to
make in a certain circumstance
let me think about how I do want to feel
today let me open my heart to life again
let me feel kindness and care and love
and gratitude and appreciation let me
let me just bring up that feeling let me
feel it with my heart let me keep
bringing it up so I can bring it up
enough times I want to get so good
at bringing up this feeling with my eyes
closed I can do it with my eyes open
you practice that and you not make a
decision to not get up until you feel
that emotion
and ask yourself can I stay in the state
my entire day
and if you can't and you go unconscious
ask yourself at the end of the day how'd
I do
where I go unconscious okay tomorrow
morning new day new lifetime let me go
again let me try again and it's the
practice it's the repetition that causes
the change now here's the beauty behind
this because all of a sudden when those
synchronicities start to happen when the
coincidences start to happen it's no
longer a have to
it's no longer oh geez I gotta go create
my life it's not like that
it's like the magic is happening you
don't want it to end like you you
realize that you are actually creating
outcomes in your life and now you're not
you're you're you're you're wanting to
do the work because you want the magic
to continue in your life and that's kind
of what I'm super proud of with our
community we're doers you know we they
do the work not because they have to
because they love all the changes that
happen in their life as a result of it
whether it's a mystical experience a
transcendental moment you know a great
opportunity in their life they're like
wow I I somehow had a hand in creating
this and so the
so the excitement of Life The Adventure
of Life the unknown becomes the becomes
the quest
I'm so so I've got to admit I'm one of
those people that wakes up in the
morning and then just gets dragged
dragged off
out of the bed by my phone the
notifications and often to my day
totally unconscious
and there's been so many things that I
reflect on in my life and go man I just
really wanna
I'll get home at the end of the day and
I'll look at certain instances where I
responded in certain ways and come and I
hate that about myself
I really want to change that
and it happens again the next day and I
could come home I think man I hate that
about myself and I really want to change
that it happens the next day and it's
been happening for two years
[Laughter]
when do you want to change that
when you're ready to change that you
will when you're when it becomes boring
and it becomes predictable I don't want
to have to wait for a crisis or you know
because now that you know you can't not
know yeah I know yeah now that you know
you can't not know and on some level
you may have a belief that you think
this is hard yeah I do yeah yeah because
I've struggled with it yeah yeah and
it's just like uh like you going
learning snowboarding and never taking a
lesson right it's gonna be like it's
gonna be tenuous it's going to be
challenging it's going to be difficult
put your time and learn how to do it and
it gets easier as you do it it's just
like you just you just have to learn the
formula there's a formula that we've
discovered that it's actually enjoyable
when you do it right and you actually
like it and people want to do more of it
because it feels so good and I mean we
see you look at the
the HRV measurements with our community
look at our brain scans these are people
that they're not faking ecstasy they're
not Faking It their brain is at such a
level of arousal and the arousal is not
pain the arousal is not fear the arousal
is not aggression or anger the arousal
is ecstasy the brain is going in this
heightened state they're making a
connection to something really big and
that feels really good and when they
realize that they've hit something
really big and it's not coming from
anyone or anything outside of them
they stopped looking for it out there
and they realize it's been within them
the whole time I think I think so many
people
want so many things in their life but
what we really want is wholeness
because when you have wholeness you
can't want how could you want when
you're whole you only want when you're
in lack
when there's brain and heart coherence
there's a level of wholeness that takes
place where a person is no longer
interested in separation or lack they
feel like they have everything they want
that's a great place to be in
and we've discovered that the more
relaxed you are in your heart
more awake you are in your brain it's
relaxed in the heart and awake in the
brain and we teach that people actually
can get good at doing that
I really want to talk to you about this
brain coherence and this heart coherence
um I have to
close off on that morning routine thing
by asking you exactly what did you do
this morning oh
this morning
uh I was up probably around
4 30.
yeah why because there's nobody that can
bother me at that time
there's no
emails there's no text there's there's
no there's my it's my time what time
were you in bed
um probably between 10 and 11 okay
is that a not enough sleep for you huh
well
no that is I think I actually measured
my sleep so I and I look at it every day
that's part of the reason I'm dragging
out of bed but yeah for me four in the
morning five in the morning is a really
great time I just I I've just
conditioned my body that way
um that's the time and and I I spend a
little time remembering what I'm doing
what am I doing what are you doing in
this meditation why are you doing this
meditation what are you about to do I
like to
just get myself in my think box
organizing what am I not going to think
about what I'm going to stay away from
what am I not going to do in my
meditation let me review that what I am
what am I going to do
let me get that all worked out then I
get in my play box in my play box
there's no thinking I've got all the
thinking done in my think box my play
box it's really about me changing my
state and so um I allow for two hours
every morning doesn't mean I always take
it I'll need it let me say that but I
allow for two hours sometimes I like to
just get my mind
straight and then I do the work I do the
work and and I like to get to that point
where when I'm done I feel like
something changed do the work yeah
what does the work look like
it's meditation yeah
it's finding the present moment getting
into the unknown it's getting Beyond
Myself disconnecting from my body
getting Beyond any thought of anyone or
anything getting me on time moving
beyond space and time
turns out when you focus on nothing
there are so many amazing things that
happen to your brain I've seen the scans
over and over again
what have you seen in the scans
well there's this thing in the brain
called modularity
and when we're living uh by the hormones
of stress and stress is when you can't
predict something when you can't control
something or you have the perception
that something's going to get worse you
switch on that fight-or-flight nervous
system and the rush of those chemicals
causes us to become alert to become
aroused and we narrow our focus on the
material world and so when you're not
able to control everything in your life
and you can't predict everything in your
life you start shifting your attention
to everyone and everything every person
every object every place and we've all
had that experience when we're under
stress and every one of those people
those objects those things those places
has the neurological Network in the
brain so like a lightning storm in the
clouds the brain begins to fire out of
order very incoherently it becomes
modulated or compartmentalized It's A
house divided against itself and those
individual compartments don't talk to
the rest of the brain and we tend to get
over focused you never notice when
you're under stress you're obsessing
about something you're over focusing
about something you're overthinking
something you're over analyzing you're
driving your brain higher and higher
into higher states of arousal High beta
brainwave patterns
we discovered that if you teach a person
to go from a narrow focus on something
physical something material and broaden
their focus open their awareness and put
their attention on space on nothing and
create what's called a Divergent Focus
the act of sensing and no longer
analyzing thinking begins to slow the
brain waves down from that beta
brainwave state to a low level beta and
then all of a sudden to Alpha if they
keep doing it sensing space tends to
cause those different compartments that
were modulated divided to begin to
synchronize
and what sinks in the brain actually
links in the brain so the brain starts
firing in a more holistic state in other
words every single area of the brain is
resonating at the same frequency and now
the brain is functioning as one
neurological network instead of
individuals and that kind of holism a
kind of
order feels really good it feels really
good
and so people practice slowing their
brain waves down not only to get beyond
the analytical mind but to cause the
brain to fire in a more coherent way and
if we're going to have a clear intention
about what we want the more coherent the
brain the clearer the intention so we've
seen in seven days even in four days
these dramatic changes in the levels of
coherence and order that take place in
the brain the brain's firing in a more
holistic State that's when the person
notices a change in their anxiety and
the depression and their PS PTSD
whatever it is there's more order in the
brain and and uh the act of focusing on
nothing and opening your awareness to
space creates that kind of amazing
change did you sign an intention this
morning I did
can you tell me what it is oh
um I want to be relaxed and awake I want
to be present with everything that I do
I want to stay in my heart the entire
day and I want to be inspired by you
know the idea of helping people change
you struggle I do yeah what you struggle
with
wow
um I run a lot of different
aspects of my company I have events side
we have a product side we have corporate
Consulting we have 250 corporate
trainers we have a vitamin company
called biocentropy we work with remote
coherence healers that actually are we
do research and they're remotely
changing People's Health we have a huge
research team with University of
California San Diego we have a lot of
players on the team we have
non-profits uh
what else do we have
we have an inner Health Coalition for
Physicians and and doctors and
Healthcare practitioners around the
world that want to teach a different
model so I have a lot of different
things that I have my hand in
um
and I think you know I'm creative by
nature and I like to be creative and
sometimes I have a lot of obligations in
terms of making decisions for 2026
decisions about things that I need to do
documentaries whatever it is and I think
I struggle with not having wanting more
time for being creative and that's kind
of the fun part of my job whether
I look at the data I see the research
and then I go oh my God I want to do a
meditation now I understand how to do
this meditation or teach this better
all the information that we're gathering
in our research is to teach
transformation better that's why I want
to close the gap between knowledge and
experience
so it's we have billions of data points
and it's a lot of time to look through
all that and to learn about it but if I
would if I would choose to do something
I would love to study the research more
love to do more teacher
create more meditations you know teach
some more unique courses and so I think
I I think one of my challenges really is
to is to be able to stay creative with
everything I have going on in my life I
think everyone that's a high achiever
always wishes they could post time I
think
um we're we're at such a level of growth
right now to just uh globally
I mean our events sell out in 10 minutes
you know five ten minutes in and we have
a waiting list of uh sometimes 10 000
people that's a problem you know that's
a and and I won't give up doing
um Live Events you know and I think it's
I won't do it online I think it's
there's something special that happens
uh in community and so I've never met
someone who is
so Mission driven and doing so well in
this department that also
isn't paying a personal cost
for the mission in some regard or
capacity well I think I've learned a few
things over the years about that
I think one of the great things number
one is I have an amazing team I mean I'm
nothing
without my team
uh and their creatives and they're cool
and they're emotionally intelligent and
they they're not nine to fivers they
share the same Mission with me they they
see the same vision they do it for the
same reason somehow they're part of that
that change in transformation
um so my team
um uh is able to allow me to do
something really really unique and that
is to focus on focus on what I love to
do more than anything else so uh my team
is a super super huge help for me so I I
think that it's an important element the
other thing that I work on I think every
day of my life is uh to be the example
of everything that I teach I I mean
that's important for me because uh
I want to be I want to be in the game
with everybody so when I see
transformation when I see Miracles when
I see healings when I see change when I
see which poor people become rich
whatever that is
and I'm a part of that I think it's
really it humbles me yeah it really
makes me more humble in seeing what's
possible for human beings and and so I
never want this work to be about me I
want it to be about you I want it to be
I want to celebrate your story uh you
know I I want I want to I want to be
there for that person when they open
their eyes and we're blind than they're
seeing for the first time I want to be
right there I want to be there I want to
remember that moment uh and then and her
Joy
um so
for me I work on on being the example uh
in every way that I can and and
sometimes it requires
um a lot you know extra time to do that
yeah
what is what is the what is the um and
then this is an interesting use of
phrase because I'm saying the word cost
is as as if it's a negative but I just I
think everyone that's leading a mission
whatever that might be and they're
really dedicated to that mission the way
that you are flying around the world
continuing to do it in person where most
people you know everyone knows you could
just do it online and you'd probably
make more money to be honest you know
there's people that just have moved
online post pandemic you'll you're
giving a level of dedication and
personal investment into this mission
that must well I assume it must come at
a personal cost to some degree
um you make sacrifices
um you have to sacrifice uh
relationships at time you know sometimes
you can't be where you want to be
um but I think that the people in my
life that love me to understand my
mission uh and and they respect that uh
sometimes I'm on six different time
zones in four weeks and and that's a lot
for my body you know but
um
God watching somebody on the stage just
the other day tell the story of how she
overcame tri-facial neuralgia in One
Moment In the Event she wanted someone
to chop her head off that's how much
pain she had in her face for years one
moment she said I have no pain that's
the first time I've not had pain in
years
uh to me like
that's worth all the lost luggage the
missed flights the uh the jet lag that
to me is worth more than all the gold in
the world I mean I don't know it's just
it's so uncommon and yet something
innating us wakes up something wakes up
in us when we see that we we forgot
we forgot and somehow we remember so
um you asked my staff what is the
greatest part of their job they'll tell
you being a part of transformation being
a part of it
being a part of that so there is a cost
um always uh
uh and at the same time I really I
really work on uh figuring out ways to
do things better I mean I think that's
one of the things I love about myself is
just learning learning from my
experience learning from my past and the
experience is the greatest professor and
and just saying okay if I had another
opportunity how could we do it
differently how could we serve better
you know how can we make it easier what
can we do differently and and again I
just have a great team that's super
committed to whether they're running
events whether they're creating logos
whether they're doing a brand whether
they're managing the website whatever
they're you know running them composing
music with me for meditations
or doing research we just have a really
people that share that same Mission and
and I think
um changing individuals one by one to
somehow make a change in the world and
being a part of that's pretty cool was
there a countless movement in your life
that sent you more so in this direction
um sure I mean I got run over by a truck
and a triathlon in 1986 in Palm Springs
California and um
I broke six vertebrae in my spine and I
had bone fragments on my spinal cord and
I had the neural arch of T8 compressing
on the cord so the typical
uh
prognosis for that you know is is uh
Harrington Rod Surgery they they put
these long stainless steel rods in your
spine so in my case it would be from the
base of my neck to the base of my spine
stabilize the entire spine
and um
I just had four opinions from four of
the leading surgeons in Southern
California and I was in my 20s and I
just I just couldn't imagine myself
living on you know addictive medications
or not being able to do
whatever I love to do physically
so I decided not to have the surgery I
just went against the the opinions of
the experts and I just thought maybe
there's a way that my my mind could heal
my body
and so um
that started my journey and somehow it
worked so I've been spending the rest of
my life studying that
had that not happen do you think you
were going to do in a different
direction sure absolutely
absolutely yeah what if the worst thing
that happened to you is the best thing
that happened to you
and that starts this this you create
this belief in your mind that you can
heal yourself using your mind well it
was kind of crazy because um I think
when you're faced with crisis like in
the situation like this we tend to focus
on the worst thing that could happen
instead of the best thing that could
happen and that's because of the
hormones of stress and emergency you
always prepare for the worst better
chances of survival if you think about
the worst so
it took an enormous amount of energy for
me to stop that to stop thinking that
way and stop feeling that way six and a
half weeks of a Dark Night of the soul I
would say because I couldn't get my
brain to do what I wanted it to do even
though I theoretically and understood it
I just kept defaulting and I spent hours
and finally I was able to to kind of get
control over it and then as soon as I
started noticing
some changes in my body that's when I
it's when I just the moment I started
feeling my limbs again and when I
started noticing I was moving a little
better
I knew somehow I was having an effect
and that's that's the moment it all
changed for me
running all these businesses Joe and you
have such an Empire of businesses and
projects and people and teams all over
the world
how have you managed your relationship
with technology because technology is on
omnipresent in my life yeah and that's
why I say I get dragged out of bed by it
Stephen I never planned on doing any of
this I never I never plan on doing any
of this I mean all the
corporate stuff just came out of a few
lectures because there were CEOs and
presidents of companies that urged me to
create a model for change for companies
and organizations I never wanted to do
that I never wanted to do Inner Health
Coalition for doctors just our community
there's an emergent Consciousness that
says please do that you know so
we're we're working on
uh in the same vein of the same Mission
giving people our community listening to
our community and creating you know more
of that for people I don't have I don't
have any difficulty if it's part of the
mission to do any of those things I
think it's uh
I think it
if I were just doing my events
and and that's it and we could just do
that my life would be a whole lot
simpler but all these other things that
we're doing now in terms of they also
bear a lot of fruit I mean the research
that we're doing right now is is I can
say right now Stephen that what we're
doing is no longer pseudoscience I can
say that now it's no longer
pseudoscience
I can say that in seven days
your body can make a pharmacy of
chemicals that work better than any drug
I can tell you that one intervention
called meditation can change a host of
different health conditions there's no
drug that does that
so if I weigh those all those different
things that I have to
evolve
in some way against the effects it's
producing it's always for me worth the
effort
are you happy yeah what does that mean
um that I don't need anyone or anything
to make me happy
that's your definition of happiness I
think yeah I mean if you have a kind of
a freedom of expression without any real
limitation in your and you're
comfortable with you and your and you
love what you're doing and
you feel good about it and sure I mean
I'm always in the river of change I'm
always looking for blind spots I'm
always working on evolving who I am I
always want to be I always want to
evolve my experience I always want to
look to see if it serves me uh so
um
Jeff sad days
I have I have days where I'm overwhelmed
by just just everything what are the
symptoms of that overwhelm
um it takes me a little bit to focus my
attention again just too many things I
have to think about so I have to take a
little time and get get centered and
organized
but do I have sad days I don't know sad
I don't really
know sad but uh kind of a days where I'm
um
kind of kind of introspective
uh without needing much emotion yeah I I
have those days yeah
If This Were to be your last day on
Earth Joe wow
and there was
just a central message
that the millions of people you know
that could be listening right now
you felt that they needed to hear
that would serve them the best and serve
as collectively the best
what might that Central message be
it's important for people to believe in
themselves I think it's really important
for people to remember that they're the
creators on some level and they have a
hand in creating in their life
and that uh
possibility is something that they
should always keep their mind open to I
think that we're greater than we think
or more powerful than we know more
Unlimited
than we could ever dream
do you realize how many people you've
helped
um gosh I don't know I don't know maybe
you must be moved by the feedback you
get because I was reading through
testimonials and messages and all the
top comments and stuff and it's really
really profound stuff
you know and I it's hard to imagine a
world where that
that doesn't touch you know
it's sit with you it's Better or For
Worse you know people stop me a lot of
times and I'll be somewhere and they'll
say hey I I know you hear this a lot but
um you you really help me or you really
changed my life and I always say to them
I never I never get tired of the story
uh it's the feedback for me that uh uh
inspires me to keep doing what I'm doing
so I love the stories I love those I
love to hear them and it challenges many
times my own belief about what's
possible so um
yeah I think I I I love to celebrate
that with people this next chapter of
your life is successful
we sit here 10 years from now and you
say Steve that was a fantastic decade
for you what would have happened in that
decade for you to say that gosh
um we would publish a lot of papers that
show um how powerful people really are
um we would have our own research center
where we could do even further studies
on cancer on all different chronic
health conditions uh we were studying
the effects of healing on others and we
have really profound data on that as
well
um
I think that the conversation in in
healthcare and Medicine could change on
some level I mean the conversations
that I'm having with researchers and
Physicians are not the same
conversations I was having just two
years ago especially when they look at
our data they they kind of fall out of
their chair I mean it's I mean as an
example a drug study
is about 25 percent causality one and
four responds and it's usually
you know 60 days 90 days a year before
you see a change
our data is between 75 and 85 percent
causality that means eight out of 10
people are getting a response and
they're not taking anything no exogenous
substance in other words
their their nervous system is producing
a pharmacy of chemicals that works
better than any drug right so I think
the conversation around emotional
regulation and emotional health could
change that's something that I'm
interested in
I think meditation could be something
that is a way of life for more people to
to be healthier and to be happier and to
be more whole
uh I mean when I started this journey
even you couldn't even say meditation in
public you couldn't even couldn't say it
in certain organizations corporations
government agencies it was not allowed
right now it's sexy now it's cool right
um so
demystifying
uh that process because there's so many
colloquialisms and slangs and idioms
that have to do with meditation
demystifying that process you know we
don't teach any traditional meditation
we don't teach anything that's based on
culture religion we teach meditation
based on the data we see based on the
brain scans based on the hrvs based on
the data that we're collecting we know
the we know the words now we know the
mihuzik we know the timing we know a lot
of things
uh in terms of transformation that has
helped us in so many ways so what do you
think is going to become sexy in 10
years from now that's not sexy now like
meditation God I hope it's not AI
I hope it's not I hope it's not AI I
hope it's something that has to do with
the human spirit
ladies and gentlemen I'm interrupting
this broadcast with a very special
announcement two years ago I started
writing a book based on everything I've
learned from doing this podcast and
meeting all of the incredible people
that have had the privilege of meeting
but also from my career in business from
running my marketing businesses my
software business my investment fund and
everything else that I've been doing in
business and life and from this I've
created a brand new book called The
Diary of a CEO the 33 laws for business
and life if you want to build something
great all become great yourself like the
guests that I've sat here and
interviewed I ask you please please
please read these 33 laws the book I
always should have written if you like
this podcast this book is for you and it
is available now in the description of
this podcast below and every single day
until it's out later this month one
person that pre-orders it that takes a
picture of their pre-order uploads it to
their story on Instagram or social media
and tags me will win a Gold version of
this book signed by me and there's only
33 copies of those available
so pre-order it now tag me on social
media when you do
and 33 of you are going to win a very
very special book for those of you that
don't know this podcast is sponsored by
Uber company that I'm a shareholder in
and I'm obsessed with my whoop it's
glued to my wrist 24 7. and for those of
you that don't know it's essentially a
personalized wearable health and fitness
coach that helps me to have the best
possible Health my whip has literally
changed my life whoop is doing something
this month which I'd highly suggest
checking out it's a global Community
challenge called The Core 4 challenge
essentially they guide you through a set
of four activities throughout the month
of August that are scientifically proven
to improve your overall health I'm
giving it a go and I can't wait to see
the impact it has on me and I highly
recommend you to join me with that so if
you're not on weep here there is no
better time to start if you're a friend
of mine there's a high probability that
I've already given you a week because
I'm that obsessed with it it is the
thing that I check when I wake up in the
morning it's the first thing that I look
at I want the information on my sleep to
then plan my day around so if you
haven't joined woop yet head to
join.woop.com CEO to get your free whoop
device and your first month free try it
for free and if you don't like it after
29 days they're going to give you your
money back but I have a suspicion that
you're going to keep it check it out now
and let me know how you get on send me a
DM much of your work is now trying to
bring bring people together in 3D and I
saw this
um as I was on your website earlier on
today I was looking at some of your
upcoming initiatives one in particular
was this walk that you're doing
which I found really really interesting
um this is the first ever Global walk
that will take place on Saturday
September 23rd 2012 this year
and all the details are at walk for the
dot world so
www.walk for the dot world and I was
reading about why you're doing this and
the words Community came up the words
illusion of Separation came up yeah I
think you know if you study the peace
Gathering projects that have been done
peer-reviewed articles of Peace
Gathering projects when people come into
a community they meditate on peace a
city the crime rates go down violence
goes down car crashes car accidents go
down economic growth goes up somehow
there's a change in the in the
collective
but when the meditation ends in the
peace Gathering project ends the crime
rate returns back to the same that you
know the the car accidents and the
violence return back to the same ceiling
value as it was before
it's not enough to just
uh pray it's time to be the prayer right
so walking meditation we do in our
community and we do a lot of them
because you got to be able to walk as it
you got to be able to do it with your
eyes open doing with your eyes closed
it's a practice so you can do it with
your eyes open so you can demonstrate it
demonstrate peace demonstrate love
demonstrate
um change for the world
and so the walking meditations there's
four types of meditations there's a
seated meditation we do a lot of that
and that's traditional there's a
standing and walking meditation and
there's a lying down meditation we teach
all of those but the standing and
walking meditation is a great way to
stand up for the world
and decide if I change and have enough
of us change we could actually change
the world so meditation starts with our
eyes closed standing up with our eyes
closed and getting into an altered state
music changes we open our eyes and we
walk as that change we embody that
change we live that change we think
about what we're going to leave behind
for a new world what what what if I
change what would be could I am I part
of the whole could I affect the whole
and so a person walks for a period of
time they stop again they close their
eyes they recalibrate they get back in
that feeling they open their eyes and
they walk again and so walking
meditation is a great way for thousands
and thousands of people from around the
world to walk for change in the world
and and and
we have such compelling data about
Collective networks of observers with
brain and heart coherence that somehow
when you have a random event generator
in our
and our ballrooms and people change
their state and they have an intention
that random events become less random
and more intentional in other words a
machine that's programmed to
SS a coin a thousand times a second
multiple times a second the more you
toss a coin the more you're gonna get 50
50 right so if you if you have a machine
in the room and and nobody's in the room
you see just kind of this line stay
right around the 50 50 mark But when you
fill that room with people
and they change their state and they
have an intention all of a sudden you
see that line break way out of normal
and a program machine that's normally
flipping zeros and ones starts behaving
very differently it tells us that
Collective networks begin to determine
reality and it's not the number of
people it's not the amount of energy you
have entropic energy it's the most
coherent group of people
so if we come together in one day and
this will be one of many walks
you leave everything behind
bring your family bring your friends
bring your co-workers bring your
neighbors you never have to have done a
meditation before we'll we'll guide
people through it we'll give them the
MP3 file and
um we have just over 800 or 900 cities
now from around the world that are from
people from around the world that are
participating and the numbers are
growing so we don't know where it'll go
but it's our first attempt to just say
if we just couldn't move the needle one
degree
and off that trajectory off that
timeline just in another timeline then
it served its purpose so so um yeah
we're excited about it it's the first
one and hopefully we'll do uh some more
I'll put all the details below wherever
you're listening to this so you can
check it out it
I was wondering is your speaking Joe I
was asking myself
you're someone that's constantly doing
research and developing new ideas and
hypotheses about the world and the way
humans are and the way the universe is
do there exist beliefs in your head
that you're too scared to share
you mean beliefs that I have that that
are from experience
or beliefs that I have that I'm that are
conjecturous either
both yeah I I have a very strong belief
that that um the probability of us
seeing the truth in reality is zero
I think that we perceive less than one
percent of reality the brain is missing
out on a lot of data
and I think that we should never exclude
ourselves
from the unknown you know I think
there's a whole part of the unknown self
that that we're unaware of that that I'm
that I think exists Beyond linear uh
time and space
and I and I do believe that that it's
real and you don't know what that is oh
I do yeah yeah I think it's a realm
beyond space and time that that I think
uh you know your eye right now is
perceiving a very small spectrum of
frequency a visible light is a very tiny
slice in the electromagnetic spectrum
and that visible light red orange yellow
blue green indigo violet is is actually
bouncing off of the slowest and most
stable form of energy called matter and
that gives us this perception of
Separation right
well that small spectrum is less than
one percent of what we actually can
perceive so I think that our senses plug
us into reality into three-dimensional
reality but I think there are realities
that exist beyond space and time that
we're unaware of that we can tap into
yeah yeah I do and I think there are
latent systems in the brain that once
activated allows the brain to transduce
that energy that frequency into profound
information the psychedelics drug drugs
work in in that in that way I think
psychedelics give a person a perception
of reality that's beyond
three-dimensional reality
we're discovering that the nervous
system makes its own Pharmacy of
psychedelics in fact we have really
recent data that shows that
um many people that have a mystical
experience in our work that have fmris
look like they're on psilocybin
yeah
and yet your nervous systems making that
that that
natural chemical
endogenously
and how were those mystical experiences
triggered I'll give you the short
version
um there's a tiny little gland in the
back of your brain called the pineal
gland and the pineal gland has tiny
little crystals inside of it that are
stacked up on top of each other
rhombohedron in shape
and that little tiny gland acts like a
radio receiver for electromagnetic
frequencies and when those crystals
become can can become activated like a
radio receiver they can pick up
frequencies that are beyond your senses
the quantum and they can transduce it's
called the transducer it can transduce
that frequency like a TV antenna into
profound imagery a very full-on sensory
experience without your senses
planes alone
explains a lot my girlfriend always
talks to me about the pineal gland in
DMT and
you know and the power of everything
you've just described
I just want to remain open-minded
because being close-minded at any point
in my life is not conducive with
progress and growth
so my my
um Desiring doing this podcast generally
is just to learn from people that have
New Perspectives on the nature of the
world and to remain
humble in the fact that I know very
little
so what you said at the end there about
us knowing almost knowing zero about the
nature of true reality or whatever that
might mean I do believe I do believe
that I know very little about the true
nature of reality and my senses have
deceived me whether it's in psychedelic
States or other states so I'm very aware
of the fragility of this experience or
you know where the truth is what I think
it is
yeah well um
I think it only takes one mystical
Moment One transcendental moment for us
to realize that um we're missing out on
a little bit of reality
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest leaves a
question for the next guest without
knowing who they're leaving a question
for
if you were made president
oh boy of this country
and you have to implement laws that
would make our lives better
what would you do and why
where do we start
[Laughter]
oh boy
um
well um
I would consider education to be a much
bigger priority for both people that
teach
that they're rewarded in a better way
and the educational system to be more
Socratic and more stimulating for people
to question and and and to have healthy
debates I think that's great
um I would consider looking at the
medical Model A little bit more and
really look to see if Health Care is
really
helping people in this country
I would find ways to
unify
different uh uh sex or or different uh
organizations or bring them together
bring them to the middle in some way I I
think
standing up for principles
instead of politics is it's a really
healthy thing to do
I'd probably try to figure out a way to
reduce the debt to end War to find ways
that we could co-exist with other
countries
I'd certainly think a lot about
artificial intelligence and decide if it
was really really healthy for human
beings
I would encourage in many ways different
religions to come together and and find
ways to to get along
I would spend a lot of time with
regenerative agriculture in bringing
life back to the soil and back to the
Earth
and figuring out ways to help the oceans
and species that are passing and and to
address healthy food food that is good
for people that that is medicine for
people
Joe thank you for your work and thank
you on behalf of all the people the
millions of people all around the world
that you're clearly helping without
really even knowing it
um I've never seen such profound
testimonials in any you know in anything
I've ever seen and also the reason I
actually have this on the table isn't
because you asked to promote me I think
your team actually said I didn't need to
put on the table but it's because one of
our members of our team
um their elderly relative has been going
through a lot of a lot of pain and
struggle in their lives
um and they read your book and it really
really helped them this week Ah that's
great so they asked if they you could
get if I could get it signed on behalf
of them absolutely which I think is a
testament to to the impact you're having
on people so thank you so much Joe it's
an honor oh thank you Stephen for all
the work you do also I appreciate it
every year around this time of year for
whatever reason I go on a little bit of
a psychological shift and that
psychological shift I think is somewhat
inspired by summer but it's also
inspired by the fact that I want to feel
strong in this season of life and as I
age strength training is my number one
form of training and the question
becomes how do you build muscle and how
do you become strong in terms of
supplementation and this is where heels
nutritionally complete protein product
is my best friend for a couple of
reasons one it tastes better than any
protein product I've ever tried two in
terms of the nutritionally complete
aspect it has the vitamin and minerals
you need it's about 100 calories so it's
incredibly light but it also packs over
20 grams of protein into every serving
try The Salted Caramel flavor it is the
bomb and let me know how you get on
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]